what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with Messiah
Complex this basically wraps up like the
first phase or at least the conclusion
of Messiah Complex wraps up the first
the first post house of M phase of
Marvel Comics people usually say it's
decimation I mean I kind of guess I
would consider it to be the same thing
but this is where Marvel kind of breaks
things off and from Messiah Complex you
basically jump into x-men divided we
stand which is actually pretty cool it's
a really cool concept but you get stuff
like a new x-force line of comics
uncanny x-men continues on x-factor
continues on and then you get like the
cables solo series you get like a
handful of things that come out of this
and they all kind of run and tell like
an intertwining story for the most part
so picking up with the idea that like
Bishop had basically shot Forge and and
taking out cable for the purpose of
securing this baby again we didn't
initially know why I mean we didn't
really know why why like Bishop was so
hardcore after this kid instead
immediately after this happens we're met
with the arrival of gambit and the
Marauders now somebody that I want to
point your attention to here for a
second is a character by the name of
vertigo now vertigo is a really
interesting concept in Marvel because
she's old she's really like old school
but she is one of these characters where
she's what's called a human mutate and a
human mutate is different from mutants
mutants have their genes activated
basically you know they go through
puberty they go through like some kind
of stressful event in their lives
whether they're a teenager they're an
adult whatever the case is and the X
gene activates but when it comes to the
character of a vertigo she's actually
from the Savage Land she's basically
kind of an experiment of sorts but the
idea is that she's essentially has like
powers and her ability is to manipulate
the nervous system more or less of
anyone that she comes into contact with
so long as they're not strong enough to
overcome her abilities vertigo just kind
of distorts your perception of reality
and so of course bishops able to hold
his own against pretty much the entirety
of the Marauders or at least to a degree
because of course it's Bishop that's one
thing to bear in mind here you're
talking about a guy who can essentially
absorb energy like any kind of energy
and then channel it back at people and
so when it comes to like gambits you
know explosive explosive abilities and
so on and so forth if this ship can't
absorb it he can channel it back at them
and that's why he's so dangerous and I
remember when it comes to Bishop there's
also an upper cap he's like a cup of
water you have to empty out whatever's
in that Cup as you fill it up otherwise
it's gonna overflow and the equivalent
of overflowing for Bishop is that he
literally blows up sand so the result is
that he's not really new doesn't really
blow up or anything like that but he is
in
capacitated by the Marauders who
basically take the baby and bail and so
from here we essentially pick up with
like the actual x-men arriving on the
scene of course the last video we talked
about how they were simply traveling to
forge since that's the last place that
Jimmy madrix and Lela Miller had
basically been sent to now of course
with Bishop basically kind of cook in
the books and say hey look I came here
to try to figure out what was going on
and you know they took out [ __ ] ACOG
cable and cables gone now and the
Marauders took the baby and now I have
no idea what happened the x-men sort of
go along with it because what reason do
they have to ask any different now this
also brings in the nature of telepaths
and this is kind of an important thing
right off the bat one of the things that
people will ask is well if Emma Frost is
one of the most powerful telepaths in
Marvel Comics and bishop's lying why
doesn't she just tell everybody bishops
lying because she doesn't have a reason
to read his mind there's no reason to
suspect wrongdoing and that's why it's
the perfect cover and so from here we
pick up with cable and this is kind of
cool because what cable initially does
is once he locates his ship he basically
sends out kind of like a telepathic SOS
to Charles Xavier and basically says
you're the only person that can help me
save the entirety of humanity and mutant
kind and so of course this leads to
Charles Xavier basically responding to
cable and showing up and saying okay you
know let's get to work and let's see
what's going on now before that what we
actually end up doing is jumping over to
a character named siren who meets with
who meets with Jamie madrix and this is
kind of an important thing because siren
is and I can never remember if she's the
daughter of banshee or like the niece of
banshee I want to say she's the daughter
of banshee whatever does she inherited
her father's voice so she's got the
sonic scream and the ability to to let
herself like she was never really
important that's one of the things that
when it comes to Messiah Complex and
really like a lot of the stories that
we're gonna see going forward it's gonna
be kind of like this huge veritable
who's who of the x-men community
virtually every single obscure character
all the way up to the most popular
characters are going to appear at some
point along a line in these various
stories so you literally get a huge tour
but in response to this what we end up
learning is that when you had Jamie mad
rocks and you had Layla Miller who had
essentially been sent into like two
distinctly different universes
what they ended up doing was arriving in
the future where Bishop was a kid and
that's where we basically got a future
that was almost identical to Days of
Future past now Layla Miller destroyed
that version of of Jaime madrix that had
gone along with her at least that that
version that one of his multiples who
was there and when it died it basically
sent all that knowledge back to Jaime
himself and that's when he says we have
to find Bishop because Bishop is a
person who's
took me on the warpath trying to keep
this feature from happening and that's
why all this is taking place now of
course this basically leads to the x-men
kind of bringing in formation but it
even picks up with Xavier talking
directly to cable and Xavier his whole
stance here when the signals were
attacking the x-mansion was that cable
was the one that's sympton there now
force cables responses I have no clue
what you guys are talking about I'm here
on a mission of mercy more or less to
save the future you got to help me out
here and so of course that's what Xavier
kind of jumps in and says okay we'll go
ahead and make that happen so what we
end up doing is jumping to Muir Island
itself now for those of you guys who
were new to marvel comic's Muir Island
is a concept that you don't really see
anymore and the reason for this is
because it's part and parcel to an age
of comics that don't really exist
anymore Marvel has for the most part
kind of abandoned the idea of creating a
more cohesive line of x-men stories I
mean you have like x-men gold and x-men
blue and x-men red but they're pretty
much divided like they're basically
separate but the whole idea with this is
that your island is a is an island that
goes way back way way way way back
really is as far back as like Claremont
and even maybe a little bit before then
but that was the home of Maura McTaggart
and Maura McTaggart was kind of like
this mutant geneticist and the x-men
universe as it existed back then when
you had Claremont riding the show are
really right in the whole line of
stories as you had Charles Xavier and
the x-men over at the Institute and then
you had Maura who would come across
various mutants and then would basically
study their genes not in the way that
she would experiment on them but she
would help them to learn how their
abilities worked that's where you got
characters like Wayne ransom Claire wolf
Wolfsbane
different things like that the work of
Maura McTaggart went you know kind of
hand in hand with Xavier and actually
led to the formation of the new mutants
so there were a lot of things that
happen with regards to like them working
together and really the history of Muir
Island itself more we end up doing is
finding out of course the Marauders
basically being here to serve mr.
sinister that when sinister gets the
baby and essentially kind of turns
around to go or at least gambit follows
him we end up finding out that sinister
is not sinister instead sinister is
actually mystique and it's been that way
for quite some time and the whole reason
behind this is because of the fact that
mystique is trying to find a way to
bring back rogue now the whole idea the
hecatombs goes back to 2007 with
condition critical parts 1 & 2 in x-men
vol 2 197 and 198 I think it was the
whole thing with this is that cable when
he traveled for the past I'm sorry from
the future to the past and
initially he didn't come on his own he
basically came with a sentient ship
called Graymalkin and the whole idea
behind it was that cable established
Providence as an island that was really
more of like a mutant refuge than
anything else but the hecatombs was
created by the Shiar empire and
initially it was just like this device
that could absorb minds the problem with
it was that over time it began to become
sentient and actually like absorb every
single mind that it came across and so
eventually it basically landed in
Providence has started absorbing people
rogue touched it to stop it and the
result was that she basically absorbed
eight billion Minds at once and it drove
her insane and put her in a coma and so
the whole idea behind Mystique's actions
here is that as the mother of rogue it
was to go by any means necessary to
rescue her daughter and to bring her
back the problem with this is that when
it comes to the whole idea of mystique
sort of trying to bring back row it
really is like potentially dooming the
entire the other planet it's a saver
daughter but it also kind of makes sense
too I mean like what lengths would a mom
not go to to save her child and that's
really the whole idea behind this now
this was done or at least the idea of
mystique doing what she did was really
predicated on the notion of what was
called destinies Diaries now destiny is
a character that goes all the way back
to like uncanny x-men 141 or something
like that but Irene Adler was basically
a mutant that had the ability to see the
future and all these different things
that she saw if they weren't necessarily
stories about like you know where you
have to stop this from happening you
know good things are gonna go awry Oh
what this meant is she would basically
record them in Diaries and in the early
days of Chris Claremont run or at least
in the early days of the creation of
Irene Adler and you know his destiny
what you ended up having is you would
basically have this idea that destinies
Diaries were kind of like a caveat it
was a way to create a story or stop a
set of events from happening like
somebody would come along and say oh man
destinies Diaries foretold this would
happen we have to stop it from taking
place and it worked because back then
Chris Claremont didn't really rely on
them as like a plot device all the time
with this whole thing what happened is
because mystique and destiny were so
close the diaries of Destiny were really
more of mystique just kind of holding on
to a trinket something from a long-lost
lover but you that information
it basically foretold everything that
was gonna happen with regards to like
Providence and the hecatombs and all
that kind of stuff and the steps that
mystique would need in order to
essentially save ro
hence the entire reason why they've been
hunting for this for this baby
is to grab it to bring it in and see if
this new mutant basically has the power
to absorb all these minds from rogue it
was
gamble and there was no guarantee what
happened now while all that's going on
you essentially have like this massive
fight that's taking place between well
really between like a lot of people I
mean you got X 4 she got the Marauders
you've got cable who's arrived on the
scene you've got x-men you have like
this huge massive battle that takes
place out there but the way the story is
told it's basically kind of a background
thing it's really more of a thing that's
just there but it's not like the main
focus instead the main focus here is
really put on like mystique trying to
resurrect rope initially like gambit
freaks out right like this happens and
gambit panics he's like why in the world
would you sacrifice a child like that
with no guarantee that it would actually
work and so what is up happening is
mystique just kind of seems to give up
when rogue simply doesn't come up and
then you basically have you know you
have you know Professor X who's givin
the baby by gambit and then at that
point hands it over the cable
essentially says jump into the future
like if what you say is true if what you
say is that this baby will basically you
know essentially has the ability to save
the entirety of the human and mutant
race then like grab the baby jump into
the future and do what you have to do in
order to keep it safe that's the kind of
important thing here because at this
point it's really more of like a
cat-and-mouse game and that's what this
turns into as it'll eventually turn into
a cat-and-mouse game between Bishop and
cable and it initially starts off right
here when Bishop shows up and sees that
basically cables being given the baby
bye-bye Xavier and then Bishop starts to
freak out at the same time this happens
of course rogue wakes up now again this
is one of those things that we refer to
as a soft reboot for all the new folks
here and the idea that you basically end
up having this this concept where a
character is kind of reworked and and
restructured by virtue of a set of
events and rogues powers are gonna be
reworked and restructured as a result of
the actions of this baby
curing her of the hecatomb you know of
strain 88 and so from here you kind of
pick up with a couple of different
people like you pick up with a battle
between Exodus and Emma Frost I'm
actually kind of on the fence about this
it's it's one of those weird things
where like writers just kind of change
characters based on the story they want
to tell at any particular point in time
it's just kind of the nature of comics
nothing is nothing is an absolute but
still I mean it is kind of cool here
because I mean you've got the various
x-men x-force various groups facing off
against you know these different
characters who are out there but the
funny thing is that Cyclops initially
takes the baby from cable and the idea
is that Cyclops wants to keep it and
raise it but then subtly though the
whole thing is brought back with like
his memories of Jean Grey and like
Madeline Pryor and like giving up Nathan
and that's the whole
is in his mind he gave up Nathan to take
him to the future so Nathan could be
saved and there was no guarantee he was
ever gonna see the baby in fact back in
the old comics and kind of what's
reiterated here is that like he's never
gonna see that baby again it was the
same thing with like Jean Grey dying
cyclopses entire entire life is mired
with loss but this really marks the
first time when he will willingly give
something up for the greater good not
because you know not because it's to
save someone's life not because it's the
right thing to do but because it's
literally for the greater good of humans
not really of humans and Newtons and so
the result is that he hands a kid over
and simply says keep her safe do not let
this kid die and so when you end up
having cable who basically body slides
into the future
Bishop fires off a couple shots and
kills Charles Xavier now the funny thing
about this is that the way the Charles
Xavier death is depicted here is almost
indicative of like the reception of
Charles Xavier dying in Marvel Comics
Professor X has died quite a few times
and the whole thing here is it like he's
like he's dead he's shot in the head
it's two panels long he's shot in the
head and Wolverines like yeah man has to
clean head shot ah there's really
nothing we can do and like what do we do
Cyclops and he's like we pray and John
that's it and it was kind of like that's
the way it goes I mean that's that's
kind of how professor X's deaths are
reviewed now and that's kind of the
problem with death in comics there was a
time when death in comics was a
permanent thing and killing someone was
significant but then Superman died and
then Superman came back and then a bunch
of writers after that were just like
well I mean is just a really easy way to
tell a story so what does kill him
whatever who cares it doesn't really
matter we can bring him back any time we
want to and that's that's kind of the
direction that you go in with comics in
the modern day but again it's kind of a
crazy thing because with Professor X
being gone it's just kind of the x-men
left to cut to sort of put themselves in
a direction to where they can start
working on their own but that's the
important thing here is unlike a lot of
other writers that you will see Ed
Brubaker in terms of what he did here
was not for the purpose of like dramatic
effect it was designed for the purpose
of moving the x-men in a new direction
where someone besides Professor X leaves
the x-men's team and so from here you
essentially jump into a whole new line
of things you get uncanny x-men that
continues on after this you get a new
x-force story you get a x-factor which
doesn't really matter you get a cable
solo series actually covers what he's
doing when he's taking taking hope and
jumping around into the future which is
actually like probably the most
significant part of the the post Messiah
Complex landscape and then you get x-men
x-men legacy which I believe
is a renamed x-men vol 2 but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys
hit this hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob port you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you guys later peace
[Music]
you